un cormorán sin fuerzas para luchar o
volar este equipo de veterinarios se lo
lleva para examinarlo todavía tiene
posibilidades de salvarse
si un animal está estable y no tiene las
plumas tan tan sucias lo que hacemos
simplemente le damos una limpieza y lo
guardamos para que pase un triaje con
otros equipos de veterinarios algunas
aves parecen no tener manchas pero
tienen dentro del pico mucho petróleo
todo negro
en esta reserva al norte de lima los
científicos del servicio nacional de
áreas protegidas intentan elaborar una
lista de los animales afectados por el
derrame de petróleo y acá hay una petro
lado el que está más arriba al fondo lo
ve
hay que ir anotando cómo van van
apareciendo los empetrolados porque día
a día se pueden estar manchando más para
no repetir para no duplicar conteos
a pesar del trabajo diario de los
biólogos en las áreas protegidas todavía
es imposible determinar el alcance
global de los daños hay cosas que
todavía no se han evaluado como son por
ejemplo
los microorganismos los invertebrados
acuáticos los peces las algas que
todavía va a tomar un tiempo en medir
cuál es el real impacto del derrame
han pasado más de 10 días hasta el
derrame de 6.000 barriles de crudo en la
costa peruana mientras 18.000 kilómetros
cuadrados de áreas protegidas están
siendo afectadas el gobierno ha
declarado una emergencia ambiental de 90
días